it was it's weird i think about it now i
i mean
there's a lot i feel like i lost a lot
of momentum t at t after t2
for a number of reasons
and i'm going to talk about this because
i feel very comfortable talking to
us uh i'm an alcoholic
now i'm not turning this into an aah no
a lot but i am an alcoholic and i had a
i was a big substance abuser and
alcoholic prior to t2
and i got myself clean and sober for t2
because i knew that i could not do that
film
with the recreational activities that i
had going on nor was i going to be able
to drink i was i had to go and be a monk
i had to focus i had to do the film
and when it's over
of course
i go back and
hit it hard in a big way right because
now i've accomplished something
and um
you'd think if i may interject that
you'd think that after doing that and
getting off the booze and having such
success that you'd think oh well look
what happened when i got off the booze
but that wasn't the mindset
because it's an addiction not for this
guy no i wasn't mature enough to handle
even though i was 30 years old you know
i was 30 when that 31 when that came out
um and
i rewarded myself
by partying for
[Music]
like two years you know like three years
like four years right until i finally
realized
what am i doing i'm i've destroyed this
great gift of momentum i've gotten i've
you really destroyed it you can tell you
destroyed it oh i feel so i feel like i
did like with what i don't think i would
put i don't think i prepared myself for
some of the opportunities i was
presented and therefore didn't get the
jobs
i think that uh
had i had
a little bit more of a mentor-ish
relationship with someone that could
have
because i shifted agents at the same you
know i left my agent with some new
agents and they didn't really know me
and they didn't know how
crazy and insecure i was and
they didn't know my story and i think
they just thought they could just you
know and and i didn't handle it well i
did not have i was not prepared for i
wasn't prepared for being famous all of
a sudden and michael i wasn't really
famous
because no one knew who the [ __ ] robert
patrick was
i was
the guy from t t2 i was the t1 thousand
did you hate that
no
uh it was it was a it was a terrifying
thing though
i mean
to the point where i realized i'm not
going to get another job either because
if i look like like like like i look
like i look like now it's kind of like
when i you know and that's the way i
carry myself now but at the time i
decided
i need to gain some weight i need to
grow my hair along i need to grow a
beard i need to get away from this guy
if i'm ever going to get hired again and
it was a year and a half before i got
hired